A property in Acme is nothing more than i, than an identifier that can be
associated with a value. That is, you're giving name value pairs that are then
become part of the syntax syntactic description of your architecture.
Examples of uses of such name value-pairs include. Visualization properties,
that is, if you are not satisfied with what Acme Studio gives you,
but you have other tools available to visualize architectures,
you might wish to communicate information about those additional properties
within an Acme description. Temporal constraints. Archi, architectures describe
systems that actually run and may have timing considerations with them, and
you may wish to use tools that can take advantage of this,
such as simulator tools. You might like to have more detailed checking,
on the data being communicated via the ports and roles, and so you might have
a type checking tool. The particular communications between the components
across the connectors to other components, constitutes a protocol. And
you might wish to enforce that protocol. Do checking on that protocol, and
so on. And hence you could use the property language to describe the protocol.
If there's scheduling constraints you could put those in.
If there's resource consumptions constraints you can put those in, and so on.